[MUSIC PLAYING]
D. FOX HARRELL: The MIT Center
for Advanced Virtuality,
you could look at it
as a way to investigate
how we can blend the imagination
with the physical world.
A lot of our work involves
simulating social phenomena,
such as discrimination
in the workplace,
bias within the classrooms.
How we see each other in
different circumstances,
depending on our background.
Ways that we are categorized.
How can we use these simulations
to spark the imagination,
to spark prospective
transformation?
We have done work on issues
of everyday discrimination,
sometimes called
"microaggression,"
using video gaming as a
platform for addressing
this kind of issue.
Our work also addresses
issues like personalization.
Sometimes people
might have a sense
of needing to be pushed
in a certain kind of area
to be challenged.
Sometimes people need to be
scaffolded and supported.
And to have technologies
that can do either as needed,
I think is a kind
of crucial advance.
ALAN SPOON: The future of
rich, educational experience
is interactive communications
in a post-pandemic world
where remoteness is
evermore important,
and where the technologies to
support that are multiplying.
This center on an
integrated basis can--
with students and faculty and
tapping all corners of MIT--
be a critically important
significant contributor
to that thinking.
D. FOX HARRELL: We are gratified
to receive an Emmy award
for interactive documentary.
This particular work is called,
In Event of Moon Disaster,
and it's a project
that constructs
a deepfake of Richard Nixon
giving the speech that he
would have given if the moon
landing had been unsuccessful.
RICHARD NIXON: Fate has
ordained that the men who
went to the moon to
explore in peace--
D. FOX HARRELL: It's actually
a beautiful and elegiac speech,
but it was never given.
It's computer generated, using
machine learning techniques--
RICHARD NIXON: --to explore in
peace will stay on the moon.
D. FOX HARRELL:
This is a project
which helps people to
understand, how do we recognize
this kind of technology?
Can we recognize this
kind of technology?
It's really a form of learning
that you could say responds
to the particular culture, not
just of the subject matter,
but of the user of
the system as well.
And I think that's
just a hallmark
of a kind of broader
approach in learning,
in which we can personalize
and customize experiences.
There is not just one truth.
And by seeing the same story
through different lenses,
that broader message can emerge.
Helping to build this
studio and lab that
uses simulation and
technologies of virtual reality
for the social
good, and inventing
new forms of learning that's
engaging and immersive,
I would say that that's
the key towards pushing
our agenda forward.